real parents don't need their kids to
bail them out of jail
you owe me five hundred dollars
that money was for me
[Music]
hi it's Matt smuckler director of
Wildflower here
with making a scene
okay ready yeah action
we all need to have a serious talk
comes in maybe three quarters of the way
through the movie it's the first time
really that we see B played with such
depth and precision by Karen and shipka
break from her controlled tough exterior
she just picked up her parents from jail
and she's at the end of her line I
wanted him to have a real family
I mean we are a real family
right I wanted to establish their family
Dynamic visually by having bees standing
in front of her parents played by Dash
My Hawk and Samantha Hyde while they
stayed seated almost like children real
dads don't miss their kids track meets
to race toy cars I had the camera up
higher pointing down at the parents and
then I used it on low looking up at
Kiernan and real parents she was
physically standing over them
reinforcing her role in the family
exasperated that she once again had to
clean up their mess
Samantha Hyde really captures her
character's childlike heart as we see
her looking around and holding onto her
dog as a security blanket well then
for me in directing this scene was to
really see Bee's vulnerability dad as
she breaks down for the first time in
front of her parents did they let you go
and her parents acting like children
avoiding eye contact looking away
knowing they've done something wrong but
are unable to apologize and accept it
why didn't you tell me because I got a
new job already Bee's anger frustration
and confusion comes to a head in a way
we hadn't seen before your mama ain't
getting this building what why
because I canceled it do you know how
long it took me to get Mom signed up for
that why would
[Music]
why because your mother is not disabled
oh that's right
Michelle yes she is it's really a
pivotal scene that propels us into the
third Act
an emotionally draining day for all the
actors and myself honestly but it was
Kiernan who dug so deep in accessed her
character's anger and pain in a way that
that quieted the entire set
foreign
[Music]